اوكرانيا تترقب وصول منظومه الصواريخ
باتريوت خلال ايام كما وعدتها واشنطن
والكرملين يهدد باستهدافها
ارسال واشنطن صواريخ باتريوت الى اوكرانيا
سيدفع بقوتنا الى استهدافها باعتبارها
اهدافا مشروعه روسيا حذرت من توسيع الصراع
بسبب تدخل واشنطن من خلال تزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ باتريوت كذلك اتهمتهم موسكو
بالتصعيد والمساعده في تقديم تلك الصواريخ
رغم محاوله الحلف تجنب المواجهه مع موسكو
لكن ربما البعض كيف يمكن لروسيا ان تستهدف
منظومه الصواريخ والعالم لم يشهد بعد اي
استهداف لتلك المنظومه
خبراء وعسكريون اكدوا للعربيه ان روسيا لا
يمكنها استهدافه صواريخ باتريوت تحت اي
ظرف خاصه خلال نصب المنظومه الذي يتم بحذر
شديد تحت غطاء جوي كثير يتم تهيئه
المنظومه في مكان بعيد عن اعين الروس ثم
تنقل بعدها الى مسرح العمليات لتفعلها
اوكرانيا ستستخدم صواريخ باتريوت للتصدي
للصواريخ الروسيه بينها اسكندر لان كيف
اصبح لديها اربعه انظمه دفاع جويه حصلت
عليها من فرنسا وبريطانيا وبولندا
بالاضافه الى اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه ما
يعني انك لديها نظام دفاع جوي فريد في
نوعه على مستوى العالم من اوروبا واسيا
وامريكا
كيف ستعمل هذه المنظومه التي تعول عليها
اوكرانيا
تتكون من ثلاثه اقسام هي رادار بامكانه
كشف واعتراض اي مقاتله او طائره بدون طيار
او صاروخ ضمن دائره اشعاعها اكثر من 100
كلم وهذا ما تبحث عنه كيف
المنظومه لها مركز مراقبه يشغله ثلاثه
عسكريين وبطاريه من الصواريخ الاعتراضيه
لصد اي هجمات صواريخ باتريوس ستكون ايضا
عنصرا اساسيا لحمايه الاراضي الاخرانيه
على الجناح الشرقيه ضمن نطاق دفاعات
النيته
ستنشر منظومه باتريوت في مناطق شرقي وجنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا لصد صواريخ روسيا التي
تنطلق من بحر ازوف في الجنوب الشرقي
والبحر الاسود جنوبي اوكرانيا
امريكي
واعطاء البيت الابيض الضوء الاخضر س وشحنه
صواريخ باتريوت الى اوكرانيا وتدريب
عناصرها على استخدامها في قاعده للجيش
الامريكي في المانيا